in the past couple days you looking at
length area volume etc these two
particular kinds of shapes we have a
special name for these because it's not
just a nice need square parallel in a
triangle sutter the seeds anyone
remember yeah the compass are very good
to meet up or like a bunch of shapes add
it together or some shapes taken away
from each other etc okay now without
going into too much detail would someone
like to stick up their here to tell me
what was the general approach not the
numbers or is there general approach for
getting to just 34 we agree with it by
the way three agree yeah okay to kill
agrees with yourself that's a plus ok
we're going to be more so someone who
didn't put any of these numbers down can
they give me an idea of how they don't
tell me the calculation tell me what
approach you talk any takers someone who
didn't write down numbers can we do
another do you bash that's okay I can
help you okay pause of course so what
are we looking at here what Kimmy's
talking that is this leg up here times
this length of it now just before we get
I mean you guys can work out the number
what is the significance of that number
once again what does it represent on
this diagram so long tell me whatever
you the entire area of the whole box
okay so if we were to draw a rectangle
all the way around its area would be and
of course the answer is 90 square it
okay that's good that's a first step
consultant pick up from where Kimmy's
left off and tell us what we could do
next if that was the way we started any
takers listen I want to see if someone
else can because i'm sure some of the
people pressure is similar way Maria
what do you reckon
okay so you can see there's this area on
the inside which isn't actually part of
the shape of what you see that's been
like someone's taken a bite out of it
but we rectangular bike okay so
therefore I just need to know how big
the by words now seven is how far it is
across here are it's a rectangle sliding
one other measurement hey okay so this
can be your date but how did we have we
know that where does that come from yeah
very good yep so you can see that whole
name and then it comes in a little bit
and that's where you get dozen strong
yeah okay so let's bring it all together
now we already said that the whole thing
is ten times nine and then we're going
to subtract the bike that got taken out
which is what is 7 by 8 56 and that
should give us 30 40 k I'm primitive
wind Rella too long I just want to
revise it how we are get my own for my
constructions off how are we going to go
that doing primula do we have all the
links that we need keep you in mind you
guys actually did tell me I just dropped
it off keeping my dad's aight i think i
think we have everything right we had
everything so you're going to go 10 plus
plus 9 you got to do that twice aren't
you ok right plus four seven and eight
and seven yeah you could do it another
way remember how we had this whole big
rectangle before right imagine bringing
this a down to here can you picture that
picture so then you got to tens you got
two nines and then you've got these
seventh in a bit and you should come out
all right all right ya know something's
going wrong yeah should be even right
what is it what do we missed how do we
get 41 what are we miss out no
I accidentally ate i actually did
tendons in a bag I don't know okay and
that's a very common error to me cuz we
saw vc10 I made that error before yeah
it's another horizontal think quite
close to it and as a consequence get a
real number ok so what was the Kofun
some 152 and it's mute all right now
there's always lots of different ways to
do a compass of figure we did that one
by having a big shape and taking bites
out of it what's a way we could do this
it would be different to that that way
James fantastic how would you like me to
split it yeah you can yeah okay alright
so we've got a tall rectangle and a wide
rectangle and you can work out the
dimensions are not figure okay